bonsoir
de très nombreuses perturbations
marqueront la journée de demain la CGT
la CFDT et la fédération de l'éducation
nationale ont en effet lancé des mots
d'ordre de grève et 16 organisations
sociales se sont d'ailleurs associées à
cette journée nationale d'action la
liste des entreprises touchées par la
grève serait trop longue à établir
signalant toutefois et parce que cela
vous conseille des coupures
d'électricité dans toute la France avec
pour la région parisienne des
répercussions sur le trafic du métro
après avoir également des perturbations
dans le trafic ferroviaire dans la
distribution du courrier dans les
services municipaux dans les caisses de
sécurité sociale ou de nombreux guichets
seront fermés des manifestations seront
organisées à Paris et dans les grandes
villes de province les organisateurs ont
placé cette journée nationale sous le
signe de la défense de la sécurité
sociale François go
les syndicats conventions sociales
médecins assurance maladie la CGT la
CFDT la scène les enseignants exigent
dans son cadre l'égalité de l'accès aux
soins
modérateur
mutuel c'est un cadeau pour cent la
charge des assurés les syndicats
réclament son abrogation
loi berger sur l'institution de deux
secteurs d'assurance sociale et sur la
réforme des hôpitaux les syndicats
demandent au Parlement de repousser
cette proposition de loi
protection sociale elle doit être
assurée au plus haut niveau pour tous
voilà les quatre objectifs principaux
par conséquent de cette journée
nationale d'action pour la CGT il existe
aujourd'hui une grave menace sur la
sécurité sociale
qui peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques pour les assurés sociaux et
d'ailleurs je pense que Monsieur baron
trompe sciemment l'opinion publique
quand il affirme que ces dispositions
vise à trouver les ressources
supplémentaires parce que les sociales
et quand il prétend que les mutualistes
y trouveront leur compte alors qu'il n'y
a pas si longtemps une reconnaissait son
gouvernement que les mutualistes étaient
les assurés sociaux les plus économiques
pour
l'Institut sienne nous sommes donc en
présence du latinte grave qui risque de
faire replonger 50 ans en arrière le
système de protection sociale conquis de
haute-lutte par des décennies de luttes
syndicale et dans ces conditions il est
normal que les travailleurs réagissent
avec la vigueur que leur a proposé la
CGT nous n'accepterons jamais une
assurance pour les riches et une
assistance pour les pauvres il s'agit de
défendre un grand progrès social de la
société française nous assumerons toute
nos responsabilités
pour Jacques Barrault le ticket
modérateur d'ordre public est une des
mesures destinées à freiner les dépenses
de la sécurité sociale
il faut savoir que cette mesure fait
partie d'un plan d'ensemble celui du 25
juillet et que les Français depuis 10
mois ont fait preuve d'un esprit de
responsabilité qui n'est pas resté sans
résultat vous savez que nous avons un
ralentissement de la dépense qui ne
suffit pas bien sûr pour assurer
l'avenir mais qui déjà est un grand
progrès nous allons pas nous arrêter en
chemin ce serait ridicule et j'ajoute
qu'au-delà de cet effort qui est demandé
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas tous les
mutualistes puisque certains mutualistes
déjà font ce ticket modérateur et bien
au-delà de cet effort je suis convaincu
que nous pouvons faire beaucoup de
choses ensemble avec la Mutualité et
personnellement j'entends mener des
actions concertées avec la Mutualité
dans des domaines comme la prévention
comme l'éducation sanitaire qui sont les
domaines de l'avenir
la CFTC FO s'associe également à cette
journée nationale notamment contre le
ticket modérateur mais sans participer
au grève en somme malgré leur divergence
les centrales syndicales se regroupent
demain autour de la sécurité sociale